that's right folks this has been my plan
all along on the anniversary of the
release of Back to the Future 1 I
reviewed Back to the Future 1 it was
always my plan on the date that they
went to the Future in 2015 I was gonna
review Back to the Future 2 then it was
like yeah idiot everyone planned on
doing that even movie theater changed I
was like all right that's me trying to
be clever that'll learn me back to the
future part 2 let's talk about some
spoilers and Back to the Future 2 if you
haven't seen Back to the Future 2 its
gonna you're gonna know some stuff about
the plot so Back to the Future 2 by its
title is this sequel - Back to the
Future 1 it starts out a couple minutes
before Back to the Future 1 ended a
refill in the segment which I love cuz
doc picks up Marty and Jennifer and he's
like roads where we're going we don't
need roads then in this one when they
refilmed it back to Pedro - he's like
roads where we're going we don't need
what roads you slap those glasses down I
was like God making it sexy then he
takes off in flight alright I have
figured this is my own little fan theory
which means it's out there on the
internet because every theory ever is on
the Internet but this is my thing we
obviously don't have flying cars
here's why because when Doc's DeLorean
took off and flew someone in that
neighborhood who saw him like Biff saw
him do it saw that he was like ooh
flying cars that's a good idea oh my
gosh I'm gonna work on that and that
person who saw the DeLorean fly in 1985
came up with the device that would make
cars fly in 2015 so because he saw cars
fly he made cars fly because he made
cars fly the DeLorean can fly it is a
paradox and that's why they have it but
because it didn't happen for us that's
why we don't have it it's solved but the
plot of this movie is ultimately
supposed to be a one-shot in-and-out
thing doc takes Marty to the Future
here's all right your kid's gonna do
something dumb with Griff which is
Biff's grandson don't let him do it
never just going to be out of there but
Marty has a brilliant ass idea this is
the idea I would have he buys a sports
Almanac from the future that shows all
the sports winnings up to the year 2000
he's gonna bring it back and make a
couple bet I would absolutely do that
right anyone out there who might come up
with time travel I'm sure you're in it
for the science which is all great and
fantastic
I'll be your morally ambiguous co-pilot
I'll get the Almanac for you don't rat
me out we'll split it 50/50 how about
that but the plan backfires old Biff
gets ahold of this thing
goes into the time machine gives it to
his younger self and then 1985 is
completely screwed because now diff is
super rich and he's married to Lorraine
he's Marty stepfather and so they have
to go back to 1955 and fix that so
ultimately this movie is the future and
then in alternate 1985 and then back to
1955 so let's go back to the original
Back to the Future for one second
ultimately that movie was pretty
stationary Barney's trapped in 1955 he
needs Doc's help to get back to 1985
pretty simple they screwed up some stuff
so he needs to fix it Back to the Future
2 has a lot more happening in it it's
one of the things that makes me look at
Back to the Future 1 as a superior movie
2 - which is funny because when I was a
kid I loved Back to the Future 2 more
than Back to the Future 1 now as an
adult Back to the Future 2 is my least
favorite Back to the Future movie not to
say it's bad it's an excellent movie
it's a great time you should definitely
watch it watch the first one first if
you haven't cuz that'd be crazy if you
haven't but if you haven't watched the
Back to the Future trilogy but if you
have a great trilogy one of the movies
in the trilogy has to be your least
favorite just has do they can't be
created equal right formula Back to the
Future one and three are pretty similar
go through time your track now you got
to get back is it's a similar movie but
it's the simplicity of it that makes it
elegant this one's like here's a lot of
stuff Back to the Future - I will say is
a great companion piece of three in fact
I will argue that Back to the Future one
feels like the isolated movie felt like
they made one because like add one then
it was successful they're like all right
make two and three so they made two and
three and they made two and three linked
together more than one even though in
two they go back to 1955 which is where
they were in one but the whole thing was
someone called Marty a chicken he's just
burned he sees rage like nobody calls me
chicken
he gets all pissed about it that wasn't
in one anywhere that's in two and three
but it doesn't change the fact that I
enjoy every time segment in this movie I
enjoy the future
I enjoy the shitty 1985 you got to see
you like oh my god
things suck here I don't want it this is
like hell and this was the first movie
when I was a kid that showed me the
concept of an alternate timeline I'd
never seen that before
this movie breaks it down in the most
simplistic way doc just draws a line
that draws an alternate line he's like
Dez where we are and I was like I
totally get it I'm a child and back to
the feature made me grasp the concept of
alternate timelines when they go back to
1955 I feel like that whole segment is
like fanservice to people who loved the
first one it is fun seeing him have to
get this Almanac back from young Biff
but dodge himself and Lorraine and the
bullies and Biff it's just he is
ultimately this
wild card in a scenario that has already
played out really cool to see but you're
like I feel like I just saw this because
you did just see it you just watch the
first one before watching this one
because you're marathoning in the
trilogy because that's what people do
the cliffhanger in this movie is
brilliant though I loved the way this
movie ended doc is in the DeLorean gets
struck by lightning boom just goes
through time Marty's like oh my god and
doc B and the doc found a way to
communicate with Marty and let him know
he's in the West and so Marty's like
there's only one man who can help me now
and it shows the end of Back to the
Future one and the DeLorean is racing
towards the clock tower and the clock is
ticking and the lightnings gonna strike
and just one of my favorite segments in
movies ever but you have to see this
through Doc's point of view honestly
I've been hanging out with this kid all
week long trying to get him back to 1985
back to 30 years in the future back to
his time boom it happened you're dancing
in the fire you're like mission
accomplished and then boom he runs
around the kumari appears right in front
he's like doc yeah he just sent me back
to the future but I'm back I'm back from
the future what is there to do other
than to pass out right there on the spot
which is exactly what doc does guys Back
to the Future - I always saw as like the
darkest of the back of the future
trilogy I mean George McFly was murdered
by really corrupt rich Biff which the
trilogy never really explores that when
he gets back home and he sees Biff Marty
never really is like you have it in you
to kill my father if the circumstances
for right you truly are an [ __ ] then
you can argue like well if the
circumstances were lined up to make
Marty a dick Marty could be capable of
some really twisted [ __ ] - who knows
especially if someone calls him chicken
nobody calls me chicken needles nobody
do is a wonderful adventure it's a great
addition to the Back to the Future
trilogy and it's an awesome companion
piece to three it sets up things that
you don't see in til three there's an
event that happens in Marty's life that
ultimately screwed up his future they
touch on it in the first half of Back to
the Future 2 you don't even see that
scenario until the end of 3 and in the
end as Back to the Future 2 is my least
favorite is Back to the Future trilogy
Back to the Future 2 is most certainly
still worth buying on blu-ray and after
today every segment Back to the Future 2
will all take place in the past alright
guys so Back to the Future 2 have you
seen it what did you think about it how
does it compare to the rest of the Back
to the Future trilogy for you what do we
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want
or click right here to see more